[Musique]
nous avons mis en place donc une mission
d'information sur la gestion durable de
l'eau donc le but du jeu c'est vraiment
d'approfondir le sujet d'aller aussi sur
le terrain pour rencontrer aussi les
acteurs les porteurs de projets on ne
pouvait pas ne pas aller dans les
Deux-Sèvres pour essayer de mieux
comprendre mieux analyser et éviter
d'être emporté par les postures pour
essayer d'objectiver le débat parce que
demain et après-demain il va falloir
s'assurer de la manière dont on va
accompagner les projets futurs donc
toutes les expériences qui sont menées
sont bonnes à analyser pour pouvoir
avancer ensemble vous êtes sur une
retenue de substitution donc une grande
réserve collective c'est un ouvrage qui
contient 241 000 mètres cubes d'eau qui
va desservir 5 exploitations dont 11
agriculteurs et donc plus de presque 20
emplois derrière
et moi ce qui me désole un peu c'est de
voir c'est barbelés autour d'une réserve
d'eau c'est un peu dommageable alors que
l'objectif c'est de se mettre autour de
la table et là on est aujourd'hui pour
essayer de d'améliorer la concertation
et dans l'apaisement
[Musique]
on a eu beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
obtenir les données chiffrées on avait
pas de date de mise en pratique et en
place de l'Observatoire des pratiques
agricoles on n'avait pas de démarrage du
point zéro de la biodiversité comme
c'était prévu ce point zéro n'est
toujours pas engagé ce jour donc depuis
4 ans maintenant
il faut donc toutes les parties
prenantes soient remise autour de la
table que les données soient partagées
que les analyses soient partagées et
peut-être que le mieux c'est de débattre
autour des données autour d'analyses
partagées autour d'enjeux partagés
demain après-demain on aura toujours
besoin de délégation agricole mais il
faut que c'est irrigation agricole soit
faite de la meilleure qualité possible
en rendant les meilleurs services rendus
bien sûr à l'agriculture mais pas
exclusivement donc c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on est là aujourd'hui